I Am Honest to God!
You know when you leave a store the theft alarm goes off because the sensor mistakenly trips as you walk out?
It's happened to everyone,...
...so I'm sure you know what I'm talking about.
Well, it happened to me just an hour ago,...
...only this time, I actually did have something on me that I had not paid for.
It was all a silly mistake,...
...but the store's security guard demanded an answer from me over and over again...
...and did not believe me at all.
It certainly looked suspicious.
I had a paperback book in my back pocket under my shirt...
...which I was wearing untucked and over my pants.
I told the security man the honest-to-God truth:...
...I normally carry my paperbacks in my back pocket,...
...so when I decided to buy that book, I naturally stuck it there as I continued to browse.
When my cell phone rang, forgetting that I had a book in my back pocket,...
...I simply walked outside to answer the phone.
That's when the alarm went off, and that's when the security guard came out to see why.
I took the book out of my back pocket when he walked up,...
...and said that I had forgotten that it was there.
He took me back to a small room where he has been interrogating me about the book.
I don't know how he's going to justify his harsh treatment of me later.